hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast scaling cell therapy
manufacturing presented by Jim Beltzer
PhD we are excited to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots and sponsored by Tomo BCT true mo
BCT is a global leader in blood
component therapeutic a phoresis and
cellular technologies it is the only
company with unique combination of a
phoresis collections manual and
automated whole blood processing and
pathogen reduction technologies to room
OB CT believes in the potential of blood
to do even more for patients than it
does today
this belief inspires the company's
innovation and strengthens its
collaboration with customers to learn
more about to room Obi CT please visit
[Music]
www.opm.gov/life herbs and on your
moderator for today's event this webinar
has been approved for continuing
educational credits please click on the
CD button at the bottom left corner and
follow the process to receive your
credits before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want and anytime you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located in the
lower left of the presentation window
type your question into the box that
appears on the screen and we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation also please
notice that you'll be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
and finally if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of the presentation window or use the
Q&A button to let us know you're having
a problem thank you now I'd like to
introduce dr. belt Sura
prior to joining the cell processing
team at tehreem obesity
dr. belt who served as lead scientist
for the Rd of Corning synthamax a
synthetic growth surface for the culture
of human embryonic stem cells at corning
life sciences he was a co-founder of red
corporation and was a key player in the
industrialization of several technology
platforms including phage display and
yeast
two hybrid he has more than 20 years of
industrial research and development
experience in a broad range of
disciplines please join me in welcoming
dr. belt sir I will now turn the
presentation over to him
today I'd like to present three case
studies in cell therapy manufacturing t
cell expansion case study viral vector
production case study and finally
producing a 10 quantum system watch
before I get to that I would like to
introduce you to the quantum cell
expansion system the quantum is a novel
hollow fiber bioreactor system that is
closed uses continuous perfusion and as
a single use system it's primarily
designed for adherence cells but we also
have some results growing Suspension
cells in the quantum we have automated
all of the necessary steps for
traditional cell culture and we have
extremely good control over the gas
exchange and the temperature in the
quantum this is the single used part
this is the awesome disposable and you
can see the bioreactor on the right and
then the tubing organizer is how the
plumbing interacts with the pumps and
valves on the console system and then to
the left of the screen you can see a
couple of the bags that are attached to
harvest bag and the waste bag so here we
have the quantum system with that
disposable mounted so you can see the
hollow fiber bioreactor in the middle of
your screen you can see the four pumps
to control the fluid input to the system
and the circulation of the fluid in the
system also on the Left we have the gas
Inlet and the gas transfer module which
is responsible for all of the gas
exchange that takes place in the quantum
system so where the rubber hits the road
is the hollow fiber bioreactor it's
composed of about 11,500 semipermeable
hollow fibers and you can think of those
as very small straws
the equivalent surface area is about 120
T 175 flaps and the cells grow on the
inside of those hollow fibers as shown
in the micrograph that's on the top
right of the screen so there are
basically two different fluid paths
within the hollow fiber bioreactor the
icy loop which runs down the center of
those straws of the hollow fiber and
basically passes straight from left to
right through the center of the
bioreactor and then there's the extra
capillary loop and you can see the inlet
and outlet at that sticking up on the
top of the bioreactor and that's
basically the bath water that fills the
space that surrounds these hollow fibers
and so there we can achieve perfusion
feeding of the cells we can use both of
these loops to our advantage so I show
here a hydraulic layout system for the
quantum with the icy loop and the EC
loop shown in red and blue and the
hollow fiber bioreactor shown in the
middle so these controls of Inlet and
circulation pumps will become very
important so with the door closed
the bioreactor is now an incubator in
fact we call it a cleanroom in a box all
of the controls are accomplished through
the automated touch screen on the front
of the machine you can see running
across the top the inlets and outlets
are described and that's one thing the
quantum is not smart enough to know
which bag you've attached to which Inlet
line so you have to call that out you
also have control of the various Inlet
pumps on the yellow or for the icy side
and in the blue or for the EC side and
you can see the bioreactor in the middle
of your screen
now our engineers have gone to a lot of
trouble to describe a number of
predefined tasks and multi-step tasks so
they're either single step or multi step
these describe to the best of our
ability all the necessary tasks that you
need to perform to culture cells in the
bioreactor but the most important part
of this entire slide is the purple
button that sits above each task
description and that's the modify button
so all these tasks are not viable to
meet your fill culture needs in fact you
can create custom tasks and link them
together to describe even as much as
your entire run in a single custom step
we track the growth of our cells by
sampling media most commonly from the EC
port there's a lure lock port that's
shown on the left but if you need to get
a sample of the contents of the IC coil
right so that's the IC loop that the
cells are growing on in that loop you
can weld off a portion of the sample
coil as shown in the right before I go
into the case studies I'd like to
introduce a card t-cell therapy
manufacturing that's in development at
room o so the basic process is an apron
this product is can be purified into
lymphocytes and then those lymphocytes
are either gene modified and then
activated and expanded finally the
expanded cells are concentrated and
washed and eventually infused into the
patient's this can be accomplished using
two remote devices so the Spector op dia
can give you a phoresis product and
lymphocytes can be purified using the
Aleut red cell separation system so I'd
like to concentrate on two aspects of
this process that utilize the quantum
system
the first is activation and expansion of
t-cells in the quantum system and the
second is the production of viral
vectors using the quantum system as well
so let's start with t-cell expansion in
the quantum system so this is our basic
cell expansion of t-cells in the quantum
system and we typically start out with
2.5 mils of a leukapheresis product or
25 mils of a looot reiated product and
you can get those either from the
apheresis or from the lucra machine we
loaded 100 million lymphocyte into the
Machine approximately two hundred and
twenty eight million excuse me of those
cells were CB 3 plus key cells those
cells were activated with CD 3 cd28
dynabeads
in a two-to-one ratio of cells to be and
then fed by continuous perfusion so
that's on d0 on day 3 6 & 9 we introduce
a bolus of il-2 and aisle 7 as you can
see on the timeline and there's a
minimal amount of circulation in the I
feet loop where the cells are of 1 mil
per minute so that's really quite slow
and our gas exchange is taken care of by
the circulating the EC loop at a hundred
mils per minute that's also clearing out
any waste products that may have been
produced by the expansion of themselves
after day six we do flip the bioreactor
once a day just to break apart the
clumps finally on day 12 we harvest the
cells and we were able to harvest after
a 12 day expansion about 15 billion
t---cells greater than five hundred fold
expansion in 12 days and in a low
harvest volume of 0.5 to 1 liter now
I've shown this same data in a different
format here so you can see on day 0 we
started out with 28 million CD 3 plus T
cells and then in the blue bar in the
last column we end up with 15 billion CD
3 plus T cells also of interest is that
we get a selective enrichment of the cd8
cells that shows up quite nicely in day
9 and day 12 if we look at the flow
results you can see that we end up with
a 99% pure T cell population and that's
also a preferential expansion of our cd8
cell as I mentioned before coming up to
about 69% in the final product there is
a significant drop in the PD 1
expression and our T cells are
expressing il-2 and interferon gamma the
activation markers so just in summary
then we had over a five hundred fold
expansion of 2 e + pd 3 + T cells over
12 days no pre-processing a closed
system automated reduces labor it can be
used in a controlled space perfusion fed
and we used a low amount of media in the
process and we have a low volume for our
harvest moving on to viral vector
production in the quantum system so many
of you are familiar with growing
incubators full of flasks or cell stacks
or roller bottled in order to collect
your viral vector supernatant and I've
heard stories of up to 16
going into a single prep so this is a
labor-intensive process many open steps
there's a clean room is required because
you've got high concentration of virus
large volumes of vector and it's very
contamination prone there are two types
of virus expression they're stable and
transient expression of viral vectors
stable trench section of retro viral
vectors is usually done using a
packaging cell line and your gene of
interest is introduced into a packaging
cell for those purposes transient
expression on the other hand involves
introducing all of the genes required to
produce the virus including the envelope
the gag and the paul-jean so you would
introduce a mixture of four plasmids
into the transient transfection mix both
the packaging cell line in the transient
expression systems has their pros and
cons so the packaging cell line is
obviously very convenient and allows for
stable expression for weeks but that
initial construction of the cell line
can be difficult transient expression on
the other hand is stable for 40 to 72
hours and it is fast and achieves
comparable titers the cons it's batch to
batch variability and difficult to scale
both of these protocols have been used
on the quantum system here's a cartoon
of our transient expression experiments
to produce lentiviral vectors in the
quantum and this was done in
collaboration with Gerhart Bauer's lab
at UC Davis for Jam Medicine Center so
the first is to load your HEK 293 t-cell
if you're in a hurry and you want to
start the next day
then you would load up at least a
billion cells into the bioreactor if you
wish to let the cells expand first in
the bioreactor you can load fewer cells
and allow them to expand so cells are
loaded and allowed to attach to the
bioreactor for 15 hours or overnight and
then when the population of cells has
filled the bioreactor to approximately 1
to 1.5 billion cells then you can begin
your transaction and so that's day 1 of
the process so the transection you add
the 4 plasmid as I spoke just spoke
about for the transient expression of
lentivirus
in calcium phosphate and you allow the
transaction to proceed for 15 hours in
the quantum and then at the end of that
15 hours you wash out and do an
induction for another 9 hours so at the
end of that time we want to collect the
virus this is on day 4 and we wanted to
be able to concentrate the virus
afterwards so there was a switch to
serum free media and we then proceeded
to feed the cells for 40 hours during
that time we continuously collected the
viral vector in the supernatant or the
conditioned media that passed over the
cell on day 5 we harvested the cells we
got back our 1 to 2.5 billion to 93 T
cells we were able to titer and
concentrate the virus particles and
determine the mo I and the T use per mil
so we've shown that the quantum system
can be used to produce retroviral and
lentiviral vectors it's automated it's
capable of achieving both stable and
transient expression systems it's a
closed system the vector concentration
is equal to what we see in Flast based
system and using engineering controls we
can control the volume of the vector
containing supernatant and in the next
slide I show the hydraulic system layout
again to show you how important that is
in concentrating and decreasing the
volume of our virus containing
supernatant so basically that's achieved
by harvesting the IC loop so you can see
in the diagram that we harvest the IC
loop into a separate bag from the EC
loop where we accomplish the feeding of
the cells and so in summary the results
of our viral vector production in the
quantum for the lentivirus we got about
2 times 10 to the 8th viral particles
per mil which was a similar yield to
what's normally obtained in the cell
stack likewise gamma retrovirus gave
similar results as youth as to what they
had been getting in their plastic base
system and there will be references for
both of these results at the end of the
talk and moving on to the allogeneic
model which is a case study in scaling
out the quantum system from one machine
to 10 machines so this case study was a
collaboration between a thesis and its
European subsidiary Regenesis and the
contact manufacturing organization of
master cell so the object was to
transfer the process of so growing map
sees in the quantum to scale that
process out from one machine to ten
machines to create a larger lot size and
then finally to see if there are any
efficiencies that could be gained and
cutting straight to the chase we found
that there was a 40% cost a 40%
reduction in the cost of goods producing
cells in this way so in the first slide
we show the technology transfer a time
line through to scale out so the first
few weeks were spent simply learning how
to run the quantum and then another six
weeks were used for process optimization
most of this work was on downstream
processing of the self product and
finally the ten quantum runs were done
in the scale out so this is a comparison
of running a single quantum system here
in the Box on the bottom it tells you
how many people are required so you can
see on day one we take two operators to
run the quantum system that's mostly to
prepare the cells and the quantum for
loading with the ten quantum system you
see in the box at the top that two
operators are also required in day zero
and day one or day minus one and day
zero but basically the intermediate
steps can be handled by a single
operator and as I said before the
harvest day is the most difficult and
here we needed more help so finally if
you look at the product that we got you
can see that the flow cytometry profiles
from the comparing the quantum produced
cells to the self stack produce cells
are equal and same the same is true for
the protein secretion so you can see
that we were able to develop a process
that can yield consistent cell qualify
quality and yield and can simplify the
progression from learning to production
and importantly there's a 40% cost
reduction in cost of goods and we were
able to produce large lots of cells so
here are the references for the
lentiviral the retroviral and finally
the scale out of the quantum cell
expansion system thank you very much
Thank You dr. Zeltzer for that
informative presentation it is time for
Q&A if you have a question you'd like to
ask dr. belt sir please do so now just
click on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
type your question into the box it
appears on your screen and click on the
send button I'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for let's get
started our first question is can you
control the shear stress and the quantum
for the growth of endothelial cells
thanks for that question first of all
there's very little shear stress in the
quantum system that's pure physics that
you've got a quarter inch Inlet line
going into the icy loop and a two inch
in diameter bioreactor there's very
little shear that happens having said
that though we can control the flow rate
of the media through the icy loop with
our pumps and if needed we can even feed
across the membrane without creating
shear stress how can I monitor the
growth of the cells in the quantum so
you can monitor the growth in the in the
quantum by taking a sample from the EEC
sample port so that's a lure lock port
that is sterile so there's a point two
micron filter behind it we recommend
that you monitor the lactate production
and glucose consumption and typically
those measurements are done once every
24 hours has the quant had been used to
culture IPS cells yes the quantum has
been used to successfully expand IPS
cells we haven't done differentiation of
IPS cells yet in the quantum but that's
ongoing in fact a recent experiment to
show that the quantum can significantly
reduce the media required to expand IPS
cells what is the media perfusion rate
in the quantum well the medium perfusion
rate typically starts out at zero or
very low so to one point one milk per
minute in the beginning stages of a
little expansion and it may go as high
as one point six mils per minute at the
end of a typical MSC expansion for viral
vectors and and other applications we
may have to go higher as a cell
densities increase within the quantum so
for the viral vector case we are running
up around 2.5 million it is there a
reason for switching to serum free media
for viral vector production ah yes so
that's a good question if you produce
your viral vectors in serum containing
media it complicates the concentration
of that virus product after you have
finished your run
so the serum proteins would quickly clog
the membrane concentrators that are
typically used to concentrate viral
vectors how are the dynabeads loaded
into the system for T cell expansions
very simple we basically mix the
dynabeads with the cells in a Cell Inlet
bag prior prior loading themself into
the bioreactor and as I mentioned yeah
the ratio is 2 to 1 what kind of media
is used for T cell expansions today
we've tried both text max and rpm I plus
2 percent human ad serum and right now
we get the best results with our PMI but
we plan to test more media in the future
so stay tuned we're almost out of time
so this will have to be our last
question how our suspension cells kept
in the hollow fiber bioreactor so our
pumps the circulation pumps in the
quantum expect cell expansion system can
be reversed so we can run those pumps in
such a fashion as to push any cells that
may have gotten out into the rest of the
ICU loop back into the bioreactor so
again we just use our circulation pumps
I would like to once again thank dr.
Belcher for his presentation do you
any final comments I just want to thank
everybody and if you have any questions
further to this please contact me at my
email that should be on the last slide
of the presentation well thank you once
again I would also like to thank our
sponsor two-room o BCT for making
today's educational webcast possible
this webinar has been approved for
continuing educational credits please
click on the CD button at the bottom
left corner and follow the process to
receive your credits and before we go I
want to let everyone know that today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through November 31st 2017
you'll receive an email from lab roots
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and we hope to see you again soon
goodbye